oh mein gott oh mein gott
ganz ehrlich leute ich hab mir einfach
keinen bock mehr muss einfach nicht sein
leute wer main kanal intensiver verfolgt
der weiß das ist mittlerweile 33 hilft
mir folgen bis gestern gab zu diesem
einen typen der auf lebensmittel steht
leute und bei diesen drei folgen habe
ich wirklich schluss gemacht wo ich
sogar in den titel reingeschrieben habe
rtl bitte lasst es doch einfach hört
doch einfach auch damit was machen sie
bringen die vierte folge aus 44 folgen
ich kann mich ganz ehrlich leute nicht
an eine history erinnern zu der es ganze
vier folgen gab und jetzt ausgerechnet
zu diesem müll aber okay ich meine ist
auch gut für menschen habe ich mir
konnte zum drauf reagieren wir schauen
jetzt rein und dann gucken wir mal sehen
wir die personen die wir mittlerweile
man muss fast sagen hast du gelernt
haben ja die uns einiges an seelischen
schmerz bereitet hat es geht natürlich
wieder um last er hat jetzt schon mal
wieder neuen job also die ich meine seit
den letzten mittlerweile gefühl 80.000
folgen um diesen jungen ist es eben auch
immer dieselbe geschichte ich meine
hilfe denkt sich da nichts neues aus nur
die art und weise wie ekelhaft das
gemacht wird was verändert sich ein
bisschen immer es ist wieder dieselbe
geschichte er
der hängt er hat es geschafft und wird
wieder rückfällig
anstatt sie einfach rauslassen und diese
bringt
ganz ehrlich haben wir noch die energie
in uns haben wir noch die energie in
unserer seele drin in unseren herzen
drin
und dass sie ein viertes mal zu geben
ich war ein bisschen dumm ich habe ein
blick in die kommentare geworfen
ich habe gerade irgendetwas von mit
wurst wasser duschen gelesen
okay leute man muss wirklich sagen lasst
muss jetzt endlich war von seiner
freundin sina los kommt das geht ja
behaupten ich mein schaut euch lasst
anlass hat ja tausende andere option
nicht mal die frauen stehen bei ihm
schlange das ist objektiv gesehen
einfach so
leute und da sind wir mittlerweile
wieder mitten im geschehen drin jetzt
sind wir mittlerweile wieder in der in
der schmerzhaften zone angekommen heute
es ist ein bisschen wie beim laufen das
gibst du diese zone wo man so ganz sie
machen kann dass man joggt einfach so
vor sich hin
das ist alles entspannt und dann gibt's
diese zone wenn man kurz vor der grenze
ist kurz von q cells und das richtig weh
tut das ist jetzt der bereich in dem wir
uns auch hier wieder rein begeben
[Musik]
was für eine traurige serie
also lasst kik hat wieder einlass
psychosen sein geistiger dachschaden
kommt in dieser situation durch
währenddessen macht sich der inhaber von
dieser tankstelle oder was auch immer so
von diesem kurs an seinem seine mutter
an
da alles ist es dass ein bisschen viel
auf einmal
was man das jetzt was hat er sich das
wasser etwa ist verschwinden lassen
tk
[Gelächter]
walter ich dazu sagen soll dass da
keiner von den beiden erwachsenen irgend
so ein verdacht schöpft oder etwas dazu
sagen er stellt mit uli einen meter vor
dem ein meter dazwischen ist nichts
nimmt sich eine wortwörtliche scheibe
käse lässt die ema auf kurzreisen in den
boxershorts und die seine mutter schlafe
gut besetzt da arbeit auch moni und ich
muss ganz allein essen gehen es ist doch
einfach nur ein einziger cluster das ist
doch einfach nur ein riesengroßer haufen
scheiße ich erstmal keinen sinn also
versuchen wir das mal aufzudröseln
er tobte stattdessen abstand an die gal
rede ich denn sagen wir richtig uns
erneut nein es ist nicht mal ein meter
und sie machen einfach nichts das geht
überhaupt nicht zehn minuten später der
streit mit seiner mutter hinterlässt
beim us tiefe spuren
kaum ist der leyen setzte andrang
unerträglich
ja was für ein streit das war doch kein
streit seine mutter hat ihn besucht an
seiner arbeit potsdam 20 sekunden
geredet seinem achten mal ein brötchen
hat ein brötchen gemacht hat dann siehst
du dich selbst gesagt was das für ein
geiles brötchen es hat eine scheibe käse
in seiner unterhose sliden lassen und
dann hat seine mutter angefangen zu
heulen
wo ist das ein streit liga das ist
einfach ein einziger trip das ist es
einfach nur geisteskranken wir dass kein
streit
[Musik]
so was kann man nicht mit joghurt machen
sorry aber da bin ich nicht dabei da
spiele ich nicht mit dir geld wirklich
diese ganze vier teile sind mal ganz
davon abgesehen dass sie geisteskrank
sind menschlich gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend sind dazu auch noch einfach so
einfach eine an satisfied compilation
nun so sagt wo man sich denken nicht mal
weißt du machst du nicht so ein junger
doch bist du krank
das ist die das ist ja gut quälerei
gegangen so etwas kann man wirklich
nicht machen
du kannst mir alles erzählen kann es mir
erzählen dass du was weiß ich dass du
nutella mit einer gabel streicht das du
nudeln mit einem löffel ist okay da
macht sein ding ja dass zuerst die milch
in die schüssel schützt und dann die
cornflakes ist zwar dumpf und jahre
macht einfach mit der hand einen joghurt
decke zu durchstoßen sodass es kommen
sogar aus bleibt da ja dass das geht
wirklich nicht
kann denn schon mal passieren
ja ja ist meine ich habe auch gesehen
ich hab's ja gesehen gerade eben also
müssen wir nichts vormachen ich habe
gesehen sie waren gerade mit ihrem
rechten bein waren sie bis zum knie in
einem joghurt drin
ich habe es gesehen sie waren bis zum
knie in einem lebensmittel becher drin
aber es kann ja mal passieren oder leute
kann kann es mal passieren
ein schinkenbrötchen bitte ja und wenn
es geht könnten sie vorher die eine oder
andere scheibe schinken noch sich in der
unterhose versteckt
das war super also natürlich nicht die
die ich dann nachher auch ein brötchen
habe aber so eine andere das einfach so
einfach einfach nett anzusehen
auf dem brötchen mit
soja der stelle sehen wir auch warum
lars beihilfen ist beziehungsweise las
schauspieler harry kurz aber nicht wohin
nicht mal hin
zwei scheiben gurken zu schneiden okay
es geht nicht darum dass verbände eine
ganze kurve kleinen stimmt sich einmal
verschneiden ein zwei scheiben halbwegs
ähnlich große scheiben nacheinander zu
schneiden hat er nicht geschafft
wer dann ab zu hilft mir hier drin
okay lass das bisschen später wieder bei
sich zu hause
er hat er hat seinen kühlschrank
komplett bombensicher versiegelt da
kommt kein mensch mehr rein leutek ein
sek kommando dieser welt kein einbruch
spezialist kann hiergegen was ausrichten
wir sprechen über vier streifen von
dünnem klebeband und einem wesen denn
nicht richtig verteilt der kühlschrank
ist unbenutzbar für immer
[Musik]
oh mein gott oh mein gott mir gefällt
überhaupt nicht was ich hier sehe
dazu werden neben den kommentaren schon
gelesen als ich kurz worunter geschaut
habe das ist die szene um die es geht
ich hab's ja gar nicht wissen was jetzt
kommt heute die frage ist nur wie lange
herauszögerte naja wir den kompletten
querschnitt ausgang der zeitpunkt an dem
zu lesen ist natürlich gekommene täglich
könnten für euch vorstandes video jungen
könnte man dieses spiel und hoffen wir
beten wir dass das jetzt letzten folge
war
[Musik]